you know canadians who are unvaccinated
now cannot leave the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm
look i got vaccinated and people took me
to task for that and i thought all right
i'll get the damn vaccine here's the
deal guys i'll get the vaccine you
[ __ ] leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for kovid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
stringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
and i don't think the evidence that
unvaccinated or that vaccinated people
are less contagious let's say i don't
think it's very compelling yeah
so
why are the vaccinated all of a sudden
the unvaccinated all of a sudden a
danger
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an author a lecturer a psychologist and
the world's preeminent lobster expert
jordan peterson my old friend welcome
back to the reuben report
hi dave so good to see you and to be
doing this again
all right here we go again we've we've
done this a couple times i thought we'd
do it a little differently this time
instead of just me tossing you up for
some questions if we did a little kind
of push and pull and churn through
some of these ideas but i guess where we
start first is you're in toronto i'm in
los angeles we we live in places that
are
seemingly really out of touch with a lot
of the things we talk about people ask
me about that a lot
how's life in toronto right now
well
in relationship to the covid
restrictions
i talked to a senior advisor to one of
the provincial governments a couple of
weeks ago he told me flat out that the
covet policy here is driven by nothing
but opinion polls related to the
popularity of the government no science
no end game in sight no real plan
and so what that means is that the the
pop part of the population that's most
afraid of kovid i know it's what fifty
percent of democrats believe that you
have a fifty percent shot at getting
hospitalized if you catch covet and 25
of republicans
and so i suspect it's similar in canada
and so policy is being driven by people
who are more afraid than they should be
and
it's well it was very disheartening
conversation because i trust this guy
and he he knows what he's talking about
and so you know
i'm i wouldn't say i'm cynical about
governments exactly because
cynicism is
it's a cheap
shortcut to approximating wisdom let's
say and you have to be judicious in your
criticisms but i still found that
extremely disheartening because i
thought at least policies that i don't
agree with the restrictive policies
were at least driven by something
remotely resembling a scientifically
informed plan and he was irate at what
had been happening enough to consider
resigning
so it's pretty appalling so what does
that tell you just at a psychological
level about fear in general if this
isn't driven by science and people hear
things on the media and then suddenly
they say okay yes please lock me in my
house please keep me in a mask forever
please keep me not going to holidays
with my family just psychologically
has that unearthed anything that maybe
you thought wasn't as intense i think i
think the thing that surprised me the
most probably was
how rapidly we stampeded to imitate a
totalitarian state in the immediate
aftermath of the release of covid now
you know if you think it through a
little bit
no one really knew how serious the virus
was going to be and so it was an unknown
threat
and so you can imagine a herd of animals
or a school of fish for for that matter
because this kind of phenomena is
universal throughout the animal kingdom
the cost of overreacting to a threat is
generally minimal compared to under
reacting to a real threat right
overreacting to a hypothetical threat is
cheap compared to under reacting to an
actual threat because if you under react
you can die whereas if you overreact you
generally just get tired for a minute so
a hurdle stampede because the most
neurotic member of the herd jumps first
and then they'll instantly follow them
and that's kind of what we did in the
early stages of the pandemic the chinese
acted first now unfortunately they are a
totalitarian state and we all followed
and that's excusable in some sense
because we didn't know what sort of
threat we were facing but then the
the breakdown it's really appalling in
canada the breakdown of our our rights
let's say for mobility uh for freedom of
speech etc it's particularly grating to
me in the canadian context because
way back in the 80s
prime minister pierre trudeau our
current
prime minister's father who was quite an
intellectual
he was very enamored of french civil law
and he grafted a bill of rights on top
of the canadian federal common law
structure essentially and i i didn't
like that at all i thought that was a
bastardization of
a great english common law tradition i'm
not a fan of bills of rights because
they're predicated on the idea that you
have a finite set of rights and that the
social contract awards them to you or
the government and i think that's
backwards it's like you have all the
rights there are
except those that are expressly
forbidden by detailed legislation that
mostly was generated from the bottom up
that's the english common law tradition
anyways everybody celebrated the bill of
rights are you protected oh my god we
all our rights are protected now forever
you know it was
pierre trudeau's major accomplishment
hypothetically now we have his son and
it's like yeah
what's it good for
my my father isn't vaccinated he decided
not to partly because they were telling
him he had to
and he has his other reasons
i have family members who aren't
vaccinated for health reasons who also
had covid twice and didn't really feel
they needed to be vaccinated again
in any case
it's extraordinarily annoying to see
this happening and to then find out that
there's nothing behind it except
like the most instrumental
and cowardly
random polling
is extremely disheartening and also
maddening and also angering all of those
things at once
and do you think it's possible that the
polling is out of whack too i mean
you've got you've been doing polling
forever right i mean this is this is one
of course it's out of whack jesus christ
you know i mean how do you get accurate
polling data well okay over what time
frame you're going to pull every day how
about every hour how about every minute
every week every two weeks
who answers the phone calls when you do
the polls how did you construct the
questions are you eliciting a particular
kind of answer because you paid
insufficient attention to the way the
question was posed etc etc so it's it's
not
guidance from the polls it's it's a
quasi-informed random walk which is a
lot easier than thinking it through but
to to see that happening
in spite of the much vaunted protection
for our rights like you know canadians
who are unvaccinated now cannot leave
the country
like what the hell why why is that and
i'm look i got vaccinated and people
took me to task for that and i thought
all right i'll get the damn vaccine
here's the deal guys i'll get the
vaccine you [ __ ] leave me alone
and did that work no
so stupid me
you know that's how i feel about it
it's like well now i have to get tested
for covid when i come back into canada i
have to get tested before i leave canada
now you know that might be the latter
issue that's an issue with the americans
and and so that's outside of the
canadian purview but the restrictions to
get back into canada are even more
astringent it's like why to get the
vaccine then if you're not going to
leave me alone
and i don't think the evidence that
unvaccinated or that vaccinated people
are less contagious
let's say i don't think it's very
compelling yeah
so
why are the vaccinated all of a sudden
the unvaccinated all of a sudden a
danger
and i certainly don't understand the
push to get children vaccinated i think
that's i think
that's i think that's absolutely
reprehensible and i also can't figure
out
norman deutsch wrote a piece in tablet
called needlepoints and one of the
things he pointed out was that if you
take the top 25 least trusted
institutions
in that group the most distrusted
institutions include
big pharma
and for good reason and he details out
the lawsuits that big pharma has had to
pay because of misbehavior on on their
part broadly speaking multiple companies
over the last 20 years and they're the
biggest lawsuits in american history
which is really saying something because
your court system is set up so that
big lawsuits are really possible right
and so i see the leftists all of a
sudden it's like big pharma yeah trust
them it's like what
what what really
you guys
this is
i don't understand that at all like and
psychologically so what's going on here
it's like well i think the underlying
phenomena is something like phenomenon
is something like
well as long as it's for health and
safety
it's always good
and you know not to get conspiratorial
here but the same damn thing is going to
happen with the climate change push
absolutely they're already it's already
being reconfigured as well it's the
biggest public health issue of our time
it's like no i don't think so i think
overreaching bureaucrats are the biggest
health uh
what would you say the biggest challenge
to our health of our time if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell